I'm Shannon bream I'm Tom shallou I'm
Maria Bartiromo and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday
December 21st 2022
I'm Dave Anthony
it's the last item on this congress's
to-do list a massive Bill to fund the
government that some Republicans support
we talked to one who doesn't Senator
Roger Marshall I'm just not satisfied
with the process in no way shape or form
I'm willing to shut the government down
I'm willing to stay up here over
Christmas to fix this problem long term
I'm Lisa Brady for many holiday
Travelers it may not be easy to get
where you're going this week and for
some even harder when you get there when
you get together with family old
patterns emerge old roles in terms of
what role you played in the family
Dynamic there's also an element of just
a feeling of overwhelmed and I'm will
Kane and I've got the final word on the
Fox News Rundown
[Music]
it's the last quack from the lambduck
Congress Democrats and Republicans have
reached an Omnibus agreement the Omnibus
is a massive spending Bill 1.7 trillion
dollars to fund numerous departments
across the government the rest of this
fiscal year ahead of a Friday deadline
to avert a partial shutdown Senate
Majority Leader Chuck Schumer says this
package represents an aggressive
investment in American families American
workers and America's national defense
Republican Senate leader Mitch McConnell
says included in that is assistance for
the ukrainians to defeat the Russians
that's the number one priority for the
United States right now and their goal
is to pass this bill in the Senate then
house before this weekend so they can
wrap up their work and head home for
Christmas
which is too much too fast for some
Republicans who want more time to read
the 4 100 pages in this bill just a
horrible budget process up here I've
never been more frustrated Republican
senator Roger Marshall is from Kansas
this may be the worst week I've had in
DC since getting here six years ago
really so why is it so bad I understand
every two years it seems Congress goes
through this almost every year maybe it
is every year some sort of an issue with
funding coming up to Christmas or some
sort of legislation coming up to
Christmas so why is this different right
Dave I think it's just the size of it
just the enormity of this budget that
we're going to borrow a trillion dollars
from my grandchildren our grandchildren
collectively this year and and next year
it's just all these uh issues coming to
to Bear right now and just feeling like
that as one of a hundred Senators I I
really have zero votes right now that
this entire budget is basically done by
four people and maybe a couple of
appropriators this is what the Democrats
want they want to delay us they want the
chaos they want us to swallow all 12
buckets of this budget there's we should
be doing this through a process where we
look at 12 different buckets of money
and going through those with a
fine-tooth comb but instead what I'm
given is the choice between a 1.7
trillion dollar bill or push it to the
house for three weeks where we could
even end up with the worst situation
over there so I I've just never been
more frustrated I've ran businesses
before ran a hospital I understand how
the budget process should work this does
not connect at all with people back home
that are running a family budget or
running a business why is it worse I
know that Kevin McCarthy and the
Republicans in the house who are going
to be in the majority in the next
Congress why is it worth course to give
them a chance to work the budget out and
have more say more maybe Republican
leverage with a budget right so I think
that this is you know a debate and and
I'm not saying that I I absolutely know
what will happen politically but if we
give Kevin McCarthy just three weeks to
do something that he will lose a lot of
Republican votes over there uh on the
budget he's not going to get all 222
Republicans to agree any type of budget
like this with these bigger numbers okay
so then he he has to walk across the
aisle and ask for some democrat votes so
then they're going to want a pound of
Flesh from Kevin McCarthy now if we can
give him three months of time and that's
really what I'm asking let's give Kevin
McCarthy three months of time to go
through these buckets one by one present
a budget but then on the Senate side the
Senate has to be willing to filibuster
something else that Joe Biden really
wants I know this is pretty deep chess
we're talking about isn't this the same
kind of I mean doing the job that you do
right everything always seems to be
Tangled Up In knots and this is what I
think people get frustrated by because
you can't seem to get any one thing done
without having seven backroom deals to
get it done
so so Dave I see how to fix this now
I've been here for six years I came here
to fix this budget issue I see how to
solve it now but I'm not given an
opportunity I'm not given a voice that
the way the process works up here again
I go back to the Speaker of the House
the minority leaders on each side the
leader of the Senate basically cut a
deal get a Top Line number and here we
are a trillion dollars in debt this year
adding to a 31 trillion dollar national
debt which I think is the number one
national security issue facing the
problem and I think it's the number one
issue that that's going to impact
schools in the future roads and bridges
and by the way this government spending
is the number one fuel in the fire of
why we have such high inflation and
we're just throwing more gasoline on it
when we borrow another trillion dollars
and print more money now your leader
Mitch McConnell said he's happy there's
an increase in the defense budget and he
set a cut in spending on non-defense so
why would he be happy and you not be
happy you're both Republicans
well
I'm going to State this I I congratulate
leader McConnell on holding off 28
billion dollars of social programs uh
he's held their feet to the fire on that
already but they're still spending more
this year than last year and I have to
even call into question should we be
increasing defense funding from
770 billion to 850 billion dollars this
year we borrowed 60 billion dollars from
our grandchildren last year for Ukraine
we're going to borrow another 47 billion
dollars
I I'm just not satisfied with the
process in no way shape or form I'm
willing to shut the government down I'm
willing to stay up here over Christmas
to fix this problem long term but that's
not going to happen is it you're you're
you don't have enough votes for that do
you no I I don't think we do but I've
not given up
um you know once they pass this budget
then everyone's going to forget about
this problem and we won't see it again
until you know September 30th when this
funding would end as well now you heard
Senator Marshall talk about working with
Democrats well he is working with two on
two different issues first one that's
tied to the ongoing drama at the border
where not only is there record surge of
migrants entering the U.S illegally a
lot of drugs are being smuggled into
including Fentanyl and Senator
Marshall's co-sponsoring a bill with
Democratic senator Gene Shaheen to
compel social media companies to report
illicit fentanyl activity and drug deals
very similar to legislation that our
president then Senator Joe Biden did in
2008 to address child sex trafficking
issues as as well ninety percent of the
fentanyl coming in this country comes
from the southern border it's the
precursors made in China they bring the
drugs in here and then they poison or
mainly our youth that every day over 200
Americans are dying from fentanyl
poisoning we want to shut off purchasing
this through social media you call it
the Cooper Davis act who was Cooper
Davis oh wow so so Cooper I never met
Cooper but I've talked to his mom many
times but Cooper Davis was a young man
would have been a junior in high school
a small High School in Kansas uh he and
his friends ordered two Percocet tablets
online he took a half a tablet and died
Cooper was not a bad kid he wasn't a
drug addict
um very innocent and he was poisoned
they had no idea that fentanyl was was
in there and again this fentanyl has
taken away the lives of so many of our
youth it's the number one killer of
young adults in America right now and
social media you believe should be
compelled to to work with you let's face
it we need to secure the Border aim I
know we're going to talk about crypto in
a second 90 of the drugs that are
purchased in the dark web are done with
crypto as well so to me social media has
a part in this and they want to
cooperate so let's give them the power
to do that all right well you gave the
perfect segue the cryptocurrency
situation I know that there's been a lot
of attention on what happened with FTX
The Exchange collapsed Sam bankman freed
the ex-ceo facing fraud charges and all
that's a separate story but with crypto
there's a push you're working with a
Democrat again Senator Elizabeth Warren
and you are trying to deal with
regulation on crypto correct
you know exactly
um listen crypto was a national security
threat when we visit with our national
security folks across the world within
three minutes they're going to talk
about how criminals how Rogue Nations
how terrorists use crypto and to fund
their illicit activities they use it to
evade sanctions uh to fund terrorism
they use it to fund human trafficking
drug trafficking as as well so what our
legislation would do is try to remove
those Rogue actors out of the
cryptocurrency uh world but but yet let
law-abiding Americans to continue to do
it to invest in it I want to go back to
the the biggest issue and that's the
know your customer part of this so after
9-1-1 we added know your customer
regulations to Banks and we would do the
same thing with crypto I still think
most people don't really understand
cryptocurrency I don't know if I fully
understand cryptocurrency I I mean you
can't walk in anywhere with a Bitcoin in
your hand and hand it to somebody like
we can with a you know a dollar it's
really hard to grasp I think and so how
do you regulate something that's so
different from regular money but look I
view crypto as like this virtual
Financial Network it's decentralized
they have a virtual coin that's moved
around by blockchain technology and it's
not you know at this point in time I
think we do struggle to see uh its
benefits but we certainly understand
this risk right you mentioned the
blockchain I mean that's a way you're
supposed to be able to track everybody
who's ever owned one of these pieces of
currency am I right you know yeah
absolutely and that's why I'm so
confused is is why do these criminals
then prefer to use it
um and the and the problem is they could
track it but they don't know who it is
you know it's so instead of a name
associated with that transaction uh it's
it's financial institution XYZ so that's
why they need to know their customer uh
and to be able to track it better I all
I can say is again ninety percent of the
of the money on the dark web is to do
drug transaction is using cryptocurrency
it's the second leading currency that's
used in sex trafficking and last year
alone 14 billion dollars in digital
assets was used in cyber attacks that we
know of so it's on the rise it's a
problem it's a national security threat
and even if you sit down with the crypto
people themselves I think they would
tell you over half of the
cryptocurrencies out there are are Bad
actors so my gosh if half of the
financial institutions that use crypto
are Bad actors someone's got to step in
and say enough enough is enough
Senator Roger Marshall republican from
Kansas she got a lot of things going on
good luck good luck with the budget and
good luck getting out of DC in the bad
weather as we get to the weekend you bet
Dave it's great to talk to you Merry
Christmas to you your family and to all
your listeners thank you so much
[Music]
this is Will Kane with your Fox News
commentary coming up
holidays just wouldn't be the same
without visiting loved ones I love it I
look forward to this holiday season and
traveling to Florida travel is being
disrupted though by a winter storm
marching across the country bringing
snow strong winds and Arctic
temperatures along with pleas to
consider re-booking flights or adjusting
road trips if you can change your travel
plans around the weather please do
Meredith mitts with AAA of Minnesota and
Iowa urging people not to risk getting
stuck some air Travelers ahead of the
storm facing more familiar delays we
were waiting in line for security
check-in that took about an hour and a
half we were prepared for the for the
for the holiday rush you know we showed
up early we were getting our things
together going through the lines but
travel challenges can pale in comparison
to what's waiting for some at their
destination a Minefield of emotions and
personalities so for many people holiday
time can be stressful and although it's
Unique to each person there's definitely
common themes Dr Karen Ruskin is a
licensed marriage and family therapist
who's been providing counseling for 30
years and a few of the common themes
include grief and loss over what wasn't
what isn't and what's not going to be
some people are going through a lot of
pain and so when you get together with
family there's often a lot of questions
and to have to confront that is very
hard
um also family history when you get
together with family old patterns emerge
old roles in terms of what role you
played in the family Dynamic there's
also an element of just a feeling of
overwhelmed because there's a lack of
privacy and I'm not just talking about
physical privacy some people think that
um privacy is about the physicality of
space which is a piece of it the other
though is about 9 not feeling that
there's intellectual or emotional
privacy so there's a lack of boundaries
because often families feel like oh I
can touch you how I want to say hello
with a hug even if maybe you're not a
touch person I can ask you what I want
because your family I can tell you what
I think because your family and the fact
is that could be a real invasion of
boundaries
um physically under emotionally and or
intellectually so those are some of it I
can go into more uh but that's a quickie
answer to that question well it's it's
kind of like a Minefield and I mean no
wonder it's so stressful how do you go
about setting some boundaries if you
need to without offending anybody
so having strategies going into a family
get-together is a great game plan and
setting healthy boundaries is not about
being where now you have your armor up
and your sword out instead it's rather
going in as a curious listener being
able to ask a question to their question
if somebody asks you a question you
don't have to answer it and you can ask
a question with curiosity and say that's
a very interesting question to ask after
we haven't seen each other for a little
while why did you ask that question so
curious questioner is one way of
creating a boundary where you don't
answer something and yet it's still a
pleasant connective opportunity another
method another technique if you will is
the direct firm response you can
literally say
I declined to answer that and you just
look at them and then you smile and
that's it it's firm it's direct and the
smile is Pleasant afterwards rather than
it being an argumentative scenario
definitely political talk can be a
stressor should you avoid the topic of
politics entirely if possible or does it
depend on the people involved
as far as the topic of politics or any
other topic mind you you get to make
that decision for you for some people
they actually enjoy a healthy debate for
others although they enjoy a healthy
debate they know their family Dynamic
it's not going to be healthy at all it's
going to be unhealthy it's going to be
toxic so if you know that's what your
audience is and that's what the family
Dynamic is it's not about avoidance it's
about Choice it's about choosing to
acknowledge this is not a topic that is
going to be an enjoyable family
get-together experience so therefore why
put yourself in the position to even
experience that so it's about Choice
choosing not to discuss politics
what if going home to see family never
ends well you'd rather avoid it all
together it's it's is it better not to
participate in family time this year and
if so how do you break that news
right so thinking about when it comes to
family and trying to decide whether to
go or not to go because you know the
pattern the historical pattern has been
it doesn't end well first think about
what's in my control versus what is out
of my control because we can't control
what other people say or do we can only
control our response right so ultimately
if you truly are confident that it's
going to end unwell for you to be with
family and you would be more at peace
being by yourself this year or being
with chosen family with friends and if
that's the choice you make you get two
for yourself and saying to family
I want you to know that although I'm
choosing this year not to get together
with family I really appreciate the
invite so very much I'd love to take a
rain check please consider me for next
year I really don't want to get into the
reason why
I hope you don't get offended this is
not about you but this year I'm not
going to be there thank you so much for
your understanding so you see what we
did there you let them know with
certainty what your game plan is and you
already inform them that you're not
going to be discussing the rationale
that is how you handle it
holiday stress can also leak into
relationships with a significant other
what's your advice for couples who maybe
have a rocky relationship with one or
both families
right so when it comes to the couple
relationship Dynamic It's always
important to call it out for what it is
don't sweep under the rug where there's
a big hump sticking under that rug for
the two of you to trip over
confronts it being able to say to your
mate this is tough for both of us
identify with what's tough for them and
identify with what's tough for you you
want to ask them about what their
particular challenge is and what's hard
for them while not being judgmental or
defensive because sometimes we can
become defensive about our own family
while judging the others it's very
important to not do that and rather to
be empathetic to yourself and to your
mate and to discuss what the challenges
are come up with a game plan together be
a team you know go couple team and joke
about it right here we go let's go we
got this so being able to come together
and say all right what should our game
plan be when we're getting together with
our families what are we going to do if
somebody's family member says something
that's upsetting who's going to handle
it am I handling my family and you're
handling yours come up with the game
plan so that way you both feel like you
can trust and rely on one another these
are amongst several tools that couples
can utilize
you've been doing this for 30 years now
do families and maybe you know
relationships in general seem more
divided to you overall either by you
know politics or other issues than when
you started
there is definitely a shift years ago
acceptance
was a major theme in my early work
as a therapist whether I was seeing the
couple or whether I was seeing an
individual
acceptance that was the theme all ages
all backgrounds we accept this is the
way it is what are you gonna do that's
kind of the theme okay the shift that
has happened is I can no longer accept
what is unacceptable to me that is the
shift that I have seen where people do
not want to accept one is unacceptable
but what happens is because you feel
obligation to family
you experience this stressful angst
because you know you don't want to
accept yet you feel like you have to
because they're family
so you experience an increase of anxiety
and not knowing is it okay to share what
it is that I'm feeling it what do I do
how do I handle it the lack of tools and
coping strategies is something that I
have seen is a real challenge for people
and therefore I have made a shift in
order to accommodate clientele to
utilize a coaching direct compassionate
yes also direct and solution driven
model because people want Solutions and
strategies it's not just about talk talk
talk talk talk about feelings they want
strategies and action that they can take
so I have definitely seen a shift in my
30 years for sure
so let's say someone takes the plunge
they're they're with family everyone's
gathered together if a situation does
start to get heated it was unavoidable
in the end
how can you help to cool it back down
well the question becomes
do I want to be the person to cool down
this heat or do I want to be the person
to step away from the Heat
stepping away can create a cool down in
and of itself sometimes though a person
then feels like they're bowing down and
that the other person might think that
they're being cowardly but stepping away
sometimes is the cool down because in
reality sometimes we're the ones who
needs the cool down so that way we don't
escalate an interaction further another
method of cool down is being able to say
the words this is an old one an oldie
but a goodie
saying I'm going to choose to agree to
disagree so you don't say to them let's
agree to disagree because people get
frustrated you don't tell them what to
do you say I'm going to choose to agree
to disagree
thank you for sharing your opinion
and that's when you smile and then you
say I'm going to take a step away and
I'm going to get some of the hors
d'oeuvres over there
so you choose now to do a combination
plot or approach if you will which is to
disengage with your kind smile no longer
with the anger and the Venom that's
coming out if you're part of that
dynamic and letting them know that you
choose to you choose to agree to
disagree so that way they know you've
heard them you're stepping away and then
you literally step away you let them
know that you are so it's not that
you're walking away from them you're
letting them know I'm choosing to so
there's an element of respect of the
dynamic even if you feel they're being
disrespectful these are a few options of
ways in which of handling heat so to
speak
hopefully folks can take some of your
excellent insight and focus on enjoying
the moment focus on enjoying the
positive and getting other people to
sort of bring out their positives to the
table as well Dr Karen Ruskin licensed
marriage and family therapist thank you
so much and happy holidays it is my
sincere pleasure happy holidays to you
and to your audience
[Music]
and in other news I'm Gianna jalosi some
holiday gifts are more appreciated than
others a new consumer survey from
contextlogic Incorporated the parent
company that operates e-commerce
platform wish has found some gift givers
and recipients have some strong feelings
about holiday presents they pulled
thousands of adults in the U.S the UK
Spain and Germany more than a quarter of
respondents 28 percent said defective
discount items were the worst holiday
gift fruitcake was a close second with
23 percent of respondents dubbing the
festive dessert as a poor gift one in 10
respondents say they weren't fan of
cheap chocolates either gifts related to
weight were also sore subjects with
respondents not liking weight loss items
like scales and gym memberships other
gifts that were deemed the worst include
out of style clothing Christmas themed
ties knockoff luxury goods and Political
Items more than one-third of the
survey's responded say they found last
minute purchasing tends to result in
some bad gifts also interesting most
Americans believe they've mastered the
art of fake smiling according to wish
almost 80 percent of the survey's
American respondents say they think
they're good at faking enthusiasm when
they don't like their gifts while many
Americans fee in appreciation when they
received a so-called bad gift about 20
percent reportedly choose to re-gift the
item they receive instead of returning
it and while those people have a lot of
opinions about bad gifts 75 percent of
consumers believe they haven't given
someone an unsatisfactory gift for the
Fox News rundown I'm Gianna jalosi
[Music]
Fox News Radio On Demand on the Fox News
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite Fox News talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
Fox News Radio newscasts On Demand Fox
News Radio and the Fox News app download
it today Raiden review the Fox News
rundown on Apple podcasts or wherever
you listen it's time for your Fox News
commentary will Kane what's on your mind
the biggest story with the least
attention two weeks ago scientists in
California pointed 192 laser beams at a
pinhead size Target of two elements and
a fusion reaction succeeded in releasing
more energy than the amount delivered by
the lasers in short nuclear fusion this
breakthrough this Innovation this story
has the ability to obviously create
cheap energy for the entire world making
each and every one of us more wealthy
the same time it undercuts the climate
change control narrative and as a result
undercuts the political platform of
totalitarians who want to control our
choices from what we drive to what we
eat so what does that mean they'll fight
it every step of the way I'll break down
the history and the depth of this story
on the will Kane podcast which you can
check out right here at Fox News
podcasts
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcasts
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
precise personal powerful is America's
weather team in the palm of your hands
get Fox weather updates throughout your
busy day every day subscribe and listen
now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your podcasts